[Music]
there are arrows more dangerous than
that one
marvel studios hawkeye is always on
target thanks to vfx supervisor greg
steele hey greg hey lorraine how are you
uh thanks for having me today oh i am
doing excellent but you know much like
kate i am dying to know more about all
of the different trick arrows in
hawkeye's arsenal so how did you and the
production team work together to create
these arrows
the props department's really involved
in coming up with a lot of these designs
which is great i mean
the the work they did in building these
you know they're like little pieces of
artwork in terms of the the complexity
and the the design aesthetic it's really
great and it all lives within the the
realm of
what's come before in the other films
and you know the arrows uh that the
characters were holding were not real
but they were based on things the
prophet department had put together like
the the tip of the pimera was you know
had a blue illumination and the word you
could read it we scan pretty much
everything we do when we're on the film
so we'll scan all the locations and the
the actors and the props also you've got
the geometry which is the foundational
shape of it and then you go in and you
try to replicate the feeling of the the
surfacing quality so the the shininess
how beat up it is you know where there's
little lights that could turn on things
like that and then you age it and try to
make it look like it kind of belongs in
the real world versus being totally
synthetic
it's definitely a lot of work but it's
so worth it when you see it in scenes
like the epic car chase in episode three
what are some of the different arrows we
see in that scene and how did you bring
them to life
so the putty arrow is one of the first
arrows that kate shoots during the car
chase once the arrow hits it expands and
creates this almost like expansion foam
type quality so to create something like
that we ended up just shooting the plate
of the truck driving and then in
post-production we did the effect
simulations on the on the glass so they
referenced material that we had found of
expansion foam and some slimes and
things like that that everyone liked and
then basically put it all together and
just kind of gave a really kind of goopy
messy look the explosive arrow was one
that was launched by kate at the
beginning of the sequence it jams into
the uh the bumper of a van and causes a
giant explosion as it flips end over end
kind of rolling towards them almost the
special effects team and the stunts team
rigged up two different events of a real
van one was to get it rolling so it
could be kind of chasing along after the
car and one to get it going initially
and then it was up to us in visual
effects to kind of help augment that a
little bit you know clean up the stunt
rigging we added some additional fire
and some other explosions to kind of
just make it all tied together amongst
the shots
the suction cup arrow is what appears to
be a very benign suction cup arrow at
the beginning of the sequence which ends
up actually saving them at the end as
clint suction cup onto a subway car as
it's speeding below on the manhattan
bridge
so the outdoor grabber arrow is an aero
device that shoots cables out from
itself and then pulls back in kate
basically fires the octo arrow into the
front of the truck that khazie's driving
it spools out all these cables inside
the christmas lot which they're driving
through and pulls all the christmas
trees causing them to smash all over the
vehicle and kind of make them drive out
of control and crash we shot all the
plates without christmas trees in the
lot so we left space in a christmas tree
lot dressed with trees that the cars
could kind of drive through and the
stuntmen could kind of do that all the
action they needed to do for most of the
shots we were putting all these
computer-generated trees that were built
you know based on some reference that we
had there's some that are wrapped in
encased in kind of a wrapping and some
just kind of furled out they built those
and then they rigged them up so they
could simulate such that if you smashed
a tree into something it would you know
all the branches and all the pine
needles would do what they're supposed
to
[Music]
merry christmas so the acid arrow is
utilized when kate and clint are
speeding towards an intersection with
the cross traffic and they need to
basically create a hole in the traffic
so they can sneak through it with the
guys chasing after them so clint hands
the kate to acideros and she's
instructed to shoot them with the
traffic lights they fly through the air
and they hit a cg traffic light pole
it burns away and they kind of fall to
the ground simmering and smoldering
the pim arrow
there's two forms of pimeras there's the
ones that shrink and then there's the
ones that grow much larger at the end of
the sequence they're trapped the car's
been smashed
and clint tells kate to take a regular
arrow and shoot it up in the sky we see
that clint has got a blue pin arrow and
he fires at it as the arrow is coming
down and it scales up and chops the
truck basically in half it was something
that we had played around with in terms
of how the arrow could go through the
truck i believe it was kevin
who had the idea he said no no shoot it
straight up and then have it come
straight down and chop the truck in half
and it ended up actually working out
really well everything in that
environment is all cg so you know the
bridge the environment of new york and
all that was all basically replicated
you know it's a real synergistic thing
between stunts and special effects and
visual effects that's one of the fun
things about the job is actually being
able to kind of work with all the
different teams to put this together
well it takes a village and just when we
think we've seen it all you pull out all
of the stops for that final battle in
the finale now what are some of the
arrows that you bring back and some of
the new arrows that you introduced for
this scene
so the luminous arrow was i think the
first arrow that kate shoots inside the
ice rink and that's basically a huge
blinding light just to try to kind of
blind them so they can kind of get some
cover
i'd say you know 95 of the shots were
shot in atlanta on a back lot for us it
was taking all the footage um that we
had shot and just augmenting what was
you know like a one-story building and
turn it into a big 65 floor high-rise
skyscraper in new york the
electromagnetic arrow is something
that's used at the beginning of the ice
rink fight the big question during prep
was when we were kind of designing this
was why don't all the bad guys just
shoot them once they're down inside the
rink so we came up with this gag of
clint shooting an electromagnetic arrow
at the flagpole and it basically creates
this electro net all around the ice rink
and it pulls all the metal based
weaponry out of the bad guy's hands and
kind of sticks it to the the flagpoles
in post we put in the electro aspect of
it with the lightning bolts and
electricity and things like that
so the assadera comes back actually in
the final battle it's before clint lets
kate use all the good trick arrows when
they get down to the ice she's basically
up in far schwartz and clint is stuck in
a tree at this point so she basically
fires it at the trunk of the tree and
caused the the weight of the tree to
actually fall over clint goes flying
everything is a hot mess down on the ice
rink special effects built us a special
tree trunk that we could actually crack
our vendor team put in a the acid that
was eating away at it you know causing
bubbles and smoke coming off it and then
the tree itself as that falls it just
has a massive amount of stimulation
going on
kate fires the needle arrow towards a
place where a bunch of tracksuit mafia
are standing so she fires it it hits the
ice it winds up small needles about you
know like a porcupine go flying out of
this thing and just stabbing into all
the guys around it just kind of causing
mayhem basically at the beginning of the
fight the actual final effect was
designed
during post biz as we were doing it you
know
we had the actual plates and we we just
basically implemented a cg version of
that shooting until the all the actors
who were miming getting hit by the the
different needles
the tranq arrow is an arrow that is a
delivery system yet again so the main
arrow goes into a guy's shoulder so it's
just a bunch of little hypodermic
needles that shoot into the different
characters but the performances again
for something like that is really what
sell it
the airbag again is is one of those
great combinations between stunts and
visual effects and second unit teams it
was something that the stumps teams came
up with in their stunt biz about this
concept of a cool airbag that could kind
of go under the characters and
grow huge and send them flying into the
air to actually implement that the stunt
team set up a bunch of cranes and they
could kind of actually pull the
characters up into the air so we were
able to actually use real people doing
the stunts versus having to go to like a
digi double all the time
the sonic concussion arrow is an arrow
that first gets revealed in episode four
and that's basically a an arrow that
creates a large kind of a three-beat
concussive
sonic blast so again we used similar
techniques to what we had done you know
creating these concentric compressed air
simulations to kind of just make it feel
very powerful and concussive
the the giant explosion era that kind of
happens at the end of the ice rink
sequence is very similar to the one that
took out the van earlier but for the
most part the lighting teams created
some interactive light for us the stunt
team rigged up some performers to come
flying through the air get up off the
ground and get pulled by these cables
and come flying forward visual effects
wise we ended up adding all the
explosion and the debris that would fly
the splitting of the regular arrow so
clint's down to two arrows with three
bad guys coming at him so what he does
is he fires one and then quickly fires
another one with greater force causing
that second arrow to cut through the
first arrow splitting it in half so he
basically creates three arrows we
created all the camera movement in
computer graphics we had our virtual set
so we could put them anywhere and just
kind of move the camera through it so we
we chased along behind the arrow in
animation and split it added effect
simulations and things like that to make
it very clear that it's a wooden arrow
the pim arrow comes back again in the
ice rink fight but this time instead of
actually making something gigantic it's
used to shrink down
something and
there's several tracksuit mafia that are
careening a big truck into the ice rink
to try to kind of smash
kate and clint as a last-ditch effort
and as it's coming towards them kate
pulls out a pim shrinking arrow and
fires it at the van
shrinking it down
you know we shot as much as we could
with with the actors in the frame
but a lot of those shots ended up just
being fully computer generated with the
trucks barreling across the plaza
because we had built our cg environment
we could just drive our cg trucks
through it we had computer generated
people standing down there as the truck
hurls towards them so after that moment
you know kate turns to clinton and says
well i wasn't really expecting it to end
that way type thing this kind of odd
moment where a owl comes in and takes
that little truck away
oh there's that now was that a real owl
or was it something that you had to
create in post with cgi it was a cg owl
it was kevin's idea to have the owl in
the tree he obviously read about the owl
that was in the rockefeller tree that
year and they called it rocky so that's
what we've called our little owl and
she's really small she's only about yay
big and
she's she looks just like the real one
and it was a very specific type so we
matched pretty much all the feathering
and everything to make it look as
authentic as possible but she's very
adorable
that she is and now looking back at this
entire series what was your favorite
part of working on it
i mean the content itself is amazing one
of the original avengers you know his
storyline and handing the mantle over to
kate bishop it's a really cool story
line that we're we're all very excited
to be working on everyone's kind of at
their a-game on these projects and it's
really neat to be able to kind of
collaborate with them that's probably
one of my favorite parts of the whole
process
teamwork makes the dream work thank you
so much greg and of course go check out
all of those trick arrows in marvel
studios hawkeye now streaming all
episodes only on disney plus